Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory. the wind and the waves. My friends, he said hoarsely, we are setting out today on a great enterprise, which will be famous in years to come. Out there are vast and wealthy lands and people such as we have never seen before. We will take them for our own, he paused. His men stared back at him. I offer you great rewards, he said, though they will be wrapped
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory。风和浪。朋友们，他声音嘶哑地说，我们今天踏上的是一项伟大的事业，它将在未来岁月里闻名遐迩。在那边有广袤富饶的土地，还有我们从未见过的人民。我们将把他们据为己有，他停顿了一下。他的手下盯着他。我给你们提供丰厚的奖赏，他说，尽管这些奖赏将伴随着巨大的艰辛。但只要你们不抛弃我，我就永远不会抛弃你们，我会让你们成为有史以来跨越海洋最富有的人。我们为全能的上帝而战，他会赐予我们胜利。话音刚落，他的一名手下升起了科尔特斯的金质旗帜，那是特意在圣地亚哥制作的。当其他人看到那鲜红的十字架和绣着的座右铭——“朋友们，让我们追随十字架，如果我们有足够的信仰，那么我们必将以此标志获胜”——他们中的一些人开始欢呼。先是一两个，然后更多，接着他们都在欢呼，声音汇成了一支合唱。为了上帝，为了西班牙，为了黄金，为了荣耀。多米尼克，这真是振奋人心，出自你即将出版的童书吗？嗯，其实它不是
about with great hardships. But as long as you do not abandon me, I will never abandon you, and I will make you the richest men who have ever crossed the sea. We fight for almighty God, and he will give us victory. At that, one of his men hauled up Cortes' golden standard, which had been specially made back in Santiago. And when the others saw the bright red cross and the embroidered motto, Amici saccama crucem, et si nos fidem habemus, vere in hoc signo vincemus, some of them began to cheer. First one or two, then more, and then they were all cheering, their voices raised in a single chorus. For God, for Spain, for gold, for glory. Ringing stuff, Dominic, from your forthcoming children's book. Well, actually, it's not
即将出版，对吧？现在已经出版了吗？刚出版。是的，我想是这样，汤姆。是的，我想它在所有好的书店，甚至坏书店里都能买到。所以，这是一个关于真正惊心动魄故事的激动人心的叙述，科尔特斯与蒙特祖马的会面，西班牙人与阿兹特克人。那是对科尔特斯说服手下跟随他，并开启有史以来最非凡探险之一的描述。汤姆，你想告诉大家那段拉丁语是什么意思吗？是的，抱歉。是的。我假设你的读者都熟悉拉丁语。当然。但它是，是什么？它是，朋友们，让我们追随十字架，如果我们有足够的信仰，
forthcoming, is it? Is it out now? It's just out. Yes, I think, Tom. Yes, I think it's available in all good booksellers and all bad ones too. So thrilling account of a truly thrilling story, the meeting of Cortes and Moctezuma, Spanish and the Aztecs. And that is a description of Cortes persuading his men to go with him and launch on one of the most extraordinary expeditions of all time. And Tom, do you want to tell people what the Latin is in that? Yes, sorry. Yes. I assume that your readers will all be familiar with Latin. Of course. But it's, what is it? It's, friends, let us follow the cross, and if we have sufficient faith,
那么我们确实是在十字架的标志下成为征服者。是的。在第一集中，你说过这里面有很多模仿罗马和希腊的行为，我想这会是一个经典的例子。但这引出了一个问题，即科尔特斯的动机是什么，他所做之事的正当理由又是什么。是的。而这又引出了一个更广泛的问题：西班牙人是否觉得他们仅仅因为对方是异教徒，就有权去征服他们？你知道，如果有黄金，嗯，他们当然会去拿。这其中有任何
then truly it is in the sign of the cross that we will be the conquerors. Yeah. In the first episode, you said how there's a lot of Roman and Greek cosplaying going on with this, and I guess that would be a classic example of it. But it opens up the question of what Cortes' motives are and what his justifications are for what he's doing. Yes. And that, again, opens to the much broader question of, do the Spanish feel they just have the right to go and conquer this because they're all pagans? You know, if there's gold, well, of course, they're going to go and get it. Is there any
理想主义的成分吗？对十字架的提及仅仅是一种装饰吗？但是多米尼克，首先，科尔特斯是被古巴总督贝拉斯克斯派去的，前提是他是一个没有志气的人。是的，一个中层管理人员，一个文书工作者。似乎就是这种感觉。所以在上一集中，我们谈到了科尔特斯是如何从西班牙来到加勒比海的。我们谈到了西班牙对墨西哥海岸的第一次探险。当然，他们此时并不知道那是墨西哥海岸。那可能是一个巨大的岛屿。以及贝拉斯克斯如何决定派科尔特斯去新大陆宣示主权。为什么贝拉斯克斯自己不去？其实上次我们没谈到这个。原因是他在管理古巴，而古巴正饱受天花蹂躏。如果你打算听完整个系列，你应该记住这一点，因为这在以后会变得非常、非常重要。在古巴现在，有一种病毒正在席卷当地的
sense of idealism at all? Is the reference to the cross just kind of window dressing? But Dominic, to begin with, Cortes has been sent by Velázquez, the governor of Cuba, on the assumption that he is a man without spirit. Yes, a middle manager, a pen pusher. That seems to be the sense. So in the last episode, we talked about how Cortes had gone from Spain to the Caribbean. We talked about the first Spanish expeditions to the coast of Mexico. Of course, they don't know it's the coast of Mexico at this point. It could be a massive island. And how Velazquez decides to send Cortes to basically stake his claim in the new world. Why doesn't Velazquez go himself? Actually, we didn't talk about that last time. The reason is that he's managing Cuba and Cuba is ravaged by smallpox. If you're going to listen to the whole series, you should remember that because that will become very, very important later on. That on Cuba right now, there is this virus that is ripping through the native population
泰诺人人口。因此贝拉斯克斯无法离开古巴，所以他让科尔特斯替他去。但大概如果你是古巴总督，你就不能随随便便去搞什么异想天开的计划。完全正确。因为如果你这样做，而且这在征服者的故事中经常发生，有人会听说某个令人兴奋的新土地，那里有更多的钱和更多的黄金之类的，他们就会跑掉。然后当他们回到原来的基地时，衣衫褴褛、痛苦不堪、浑身是水蛭，
of the Tainos. And Velazquez therefore can't leave Cuba, so he gets Cortes to go for him. But also presumably if you're the governor of Cuba, you can't then go wanging off on some kind of harebrained scheme. Exactly right. Because if you do, and this often happens in the story of the conquistadors, somebody will hear of some exciting new land with more money and more gold and whatnot, and they'll go off. And then when they get back to their original base, bedraggled, miserable, covered with leeches,
他们回来后会发现一切都搞砸了，别人已经占领了他们的宫殿，然后他们就陷入了无休止的法律诉讼中。西班牙人非常、非常讲究法律。你谈到了科尔特斯的动机。我认为这是一个非常引人入胜的问题。他是否觉得他可以去拿他想要的东西，因为他是基督徒，而这些人是异教徒？因为他也是一名律师。他也有法律背景。所以他意识到这一切。他确实意识到了。我想思考这个问题的一种方式是思考
they'll get back and they'll find that it's all gone to pot and somebody else has taken their palace and then they're in endless legal cases. The Spanish are very, very legalistic. And you talked about their Cortes' motives. I think it's a really fascinating question. Does he feel that he can go and take what he wants because he's a Christian and because these people are pagans? Because he's also a lawyer. He has a legal background as well. So he's aware of all this. He does. And I guess one way to think about this is to think
他被告知了什么？他被告知要做什么？所以我们知道贝拉斯克斯的命令是什么。贝拉斯克斯说，向西走，看看我侄子胡安·德·格里哈尔瓦发现的这些新土地。我希望你找到格里哈尔瓦并给他一切协助。所以在贝拉斯克斯看来，他不知道格里哈尔瓦顺便说一下已经在回来的路上了。在他看来，科尔特斯算是二号人物，他自己的侄子才是真正负责这一切事务的人。他明确对科尔特斯说，你要传播基督教福音。那个假设，汤姆，关于十字架的事情，现在肯定存在，一些历史学家喜欢淡化这一点，因为他们说殖民主义全是关于贪婪和你知道雇佣兵动机
about what's he been told? What's he been told to do? So we know what Velazquez's orders were. Velazquez said, go west, have a look around at these new lands that my nephew, Juan de Grialba, has discovered. I want you to find Grialba and to give him all assistance. So in Velazquez's mind, he doesn't know that Grialba, by the way, is already on his way back. In his mind, Cortés is kind of the number two, that his own nephew is the person who's really going to be in charge of all this business. He explicitly says to Cortés, you will spread the gospel of Christianity. That assumption, Tom, the thing about the cross, is definitely there now some historians like to downplay that because they say colonialism is all about greed and you know mercenary motives
以及残忍之类的，但当然他们这么说只是因为他们有基督教的视角，对吧？对，对，我的意思是，我们之前和哥伦布谈过这个问题，我不会再深入讨论了，但是的，我认为许多当代历史学家对基督教化过程的态度存在深刻的矛盾。因为认为弱者、被压迫者、被征服者具有比征服者更高的价值这一假设，本身就源于基督教的假设。这很公平，汤姆。最后的人将成为第一，第一的人将成为最后。是的。我以前从未听过你提出这个论点。我会再提一次。墨西哥历史学家费尔南多·塞万提斯，他常驻英国布里斯托大学，
and cruelty and stuff but of course they're only saying that because they have the christian perspective right right i i mean we've talked about this before with the columbus i won't go into it again but yeah there's a deep ambivalence in the attitude, I think, of many contemporary historians towards the process of Christianization. Because the assumption that the weak, the oppressed, the conquered have a value that is greater than that of their conquerors, itself derives from Christian assumptions. That's fair enough, Tom. The last shall be first, the first shall be last. Yes. I've never heard you make that argument before. I'll make it again. The Mexican historian, Fernando Cervantes, who's based in Britain at the University of Bristol,
在他最近的著作《征服者》中，他说，如果你不理解征服者是认真地想要成为基督徒，他们是真诚的，你就不会理解16世纪发生的事情，这个人类历史上绝对的关键时刻。我们所知道的关于科尔特斯的一切都表明他实际上相当虔诚，他确实相信。但多米尼克，再次触及我们之前提到的事情，我们谈到了拉斯·卡萨斯。是的，那个说泰诺人有灵魂的修士。是的，他认为作为人类，他们拥有和基督徒一样的权利。当时西班牙人之间正在进行一场关于他们作为基督徒的职责是什么的争论。是去，
in his recent book, Conquistadores, he says, you will not understand what happened in the 16th century, this absolute hinge moment in human history, if you don't appreciate that the conquistadors are serious about being Christians, they genuinely mean it. Everything we know about Cortes suggests that he was actually quite pious, that he really believes. But also, Dominic, just again to touch on something that we've mentioned before, we talked about Las Casas. Yeah, the friar who says the Tainos have souls. Yes, and who argues that as human beings, they have rights just as Christians do. And there is an argument ongoing among the Spanish at this time about what their duty as Christians are. Is it to go out and,
如果需要的话，用剑尖强加基督教吗？还是说这些指控比那更矛盾？我认为这绝对正确。对帝国的焦虑从一开始就存在。哦，绝对是。所以正如你所说，巴托洛梅·德·拉斯·卡萨斯，多年来，他一直在四处传教，实际上是在向征服者传教，并说，你们在做魔鬼的工作。这太可怕了。我们应该对原住民非常友善。我们应该为他们建造教堂、医院和漂亮的小村庄。
if needs be, impose Christianity at the point of a sword? Or are the charges altogether more ambivalent than that? I think that's absolutely right. The anxiety about empire is there from the beginning. Oh, it definitely is. So as you said, Las Casas, Bartolome de Las Casas, for years, he's been going around preaching and indeed preaching to the conquistadors and saying, you're doing the devil's work. This is terrible. We should be very kind to the native peoples. We should build churches for them and hospitals and nice little villages.
我们应该让他们成为西班牙人，但不应该压迫他们，把他们变成奴隶等等。所以你是绝对正确的。这种矛盾是存在的。我认为关键在于科尔特斯带着非常、非常复杂的动机去，因为他有复杂的指令。所以贝拉斯克斯说，我希望你绘制尤卡坦半岛的海岸图。我希望你看看是否有通往中国和印度的捷径。他们还在谈论所有这些事情。他们还没有放弃中国的想法。但这里有一件奇怪的事情。贝拉斯克斯明确对他说，有亚马逊人吗？我希望你查明是否有任何亚马逊人。他还说，
We should make them Spanish, but we shouldn't oppress them and turn them into slaves and all of this stuff. So you're absolutely right. The ambivalence is there. I think the thing is that Cortes goes with very, very complicated motives because he's got complicated instructions. So Velazquez says, I want you to chart the coast of the Yucatan Peninsula. I want you to see if there is a shortcut to China and India. They're still going on about all that business. They haven't given up on the Chinese idea. But here's a weird thing. Velazquez explicitly says to him, are there Amazons? I want you to find out if there are any Amazons. He also says,
我们在古巴听到了关于长着大耳朵的人和其他长着狗脸的人的报告。他们在那儿吗？找到狗人。这里有怪物。是的。请找到狗人。他还说，还有黄金。我希望你查明我们上次谈到的托托纳克人，他们从哪里得到的黄金，以及内陆这个城市里的这些人是谁，他们有很多黄金吗？这些是非常矛盾的指令。沿着海岸走，但要找到长着狗头的人、黄金，并调查那个城市，但汤姆，他绝对没有说的是，他没有说征服这些土地，当科尔特斯最终做了或看起来做了这件事时，在古巴的贝拉斯克斯感到愤怒。对。
we have heard reports on Cuba of people with huge ears and others with faces like dogs. Are they out there? Find the dog people. Here be monsters. Yeah. Find the dog people, please. He also says, and gold. I want you to find out where the Totonacs, who we talked about last time, where they've got their gold from, and who are these people in this city inland, and have they got loads of gold? These are very contradictory instructions. Hug the coast coast but find people with heads like dogs gold and investigate the city but here's what he absolutely doesn't say tom he does not say conquer these lands and when cortez ends up doing or appearing to do just that velazquezquez on Cuba is outraged. Right.
这也是故事的重要部分，不是吗？是的。这从来不是一部分。他实际上对科尔特斯说，睡在你的船上。不要睡在陆地上。因为当然，贝拉斯克斯有一部分认为，这一定是给我的。我希望把它作为我的财务，这是我的养老金。我不希望科尔特斯带着我的养老金跑掉。
And that's an important part of the story as well, isn't it? Yeah. This is never part. He actually says to Cortes, sleep on your ships. Do not sleep on land. Because of course, there's a bit of Velazquez that thinks, this must be for me. I want to have this as my financial, this is my pension. I don't want Cortes running off with my pension.
而且我不认为他起初认为科尔特斯会那样做。但关于科尔特斯，最迷人的是这一点。从一开始，这个曾经是默默无闻的公证人，这个无名小卒，这就是我认为表明他实际上不是无名小卒的原因，他身上有一些野心、机会主义，随你怎么称呼。因为从一开始，他一拿到指令，就立即超越了它们。所以他就像，再次追随你在上一集中做的类比，他是马克
And I don't think he thinks at first that Cortez will do that. But here's the fascinating thing about Cortez. Right from the start, this guy who's been this obscure notary, this nobody, and this is what I think shows that he's actually not a nobody, that there is some ambition, opportunism, call it what you will, in him. Because right from the start, as soon as he gets the instructions, he immediately goes beyond them. So he's like, again, to pursue an analogy you made in the previous episode, he is Mark
扎克伯格，而贝拉斯克斯就像那对双胞胎。文克莱沃斯双胞胎。文克莱沃斯双胞胎。是的，他是。是的。他是那种经营一家科技公司的人，你以为你和他合伙，结果周一早上你发现他换了锁，给公司改了名，并且——
Zuckerberg and Velazquez is like those two twins. The Winklevoss twins. The Winklevoss twins. Yes, he is. Yes. He is somebody who's, you know, he's the kind of person who's running a tech company and you think you're in partnership with him and you arrive on Monday morning to find he's changed the locks, renamed the company and-
在股票市场上赚了数十亿。是的。是的。你失去了所有的股份。安德鲁·加菲尔德在《社交网络》中扮演了这个角色。我不记得那个角色的名字了。他愤怒地赶到，发现自己被关在公司门外。这就是科尔特斯和贝拉斯克斯的处境，
Has made billions on the stock exchange. Yes. Yeah. You've lost all your shares. Andrew Garfield plays this person in the social network. I can't remember what the character's name is. And he arrives outraged to find he's been shut out of the company. This is the position of Cortes and Velasquez,
因为科尔特斯做的第一件事就是招募那个带来黄金消息的人。所以这个叫佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多的家伙，正如我上次所说，我们以后会更多地谈论他。他是一个有魅力、某种程度上令人眼花缭乱、迷人，但极其无情、嗜血且脾气暴躁的角色。阿尔瓦拉多有兄弟，他们有伙伴。他们有一种派系，他们的派系会涌入。他们就像，太好了，我们会参加这次航行。通常是亲戚，不是吗？通常是兄弟、堂兄弟等等。
because the first thing Cortes does is to recruit the guy who brought the message about the gold. So this guy called Pedro de Alvarado, who is, as I said last time, we'll talk about him more later. He is a charismatic, a sort of dazzling, charming, but utterly ruthless and bloodthirsty and hot-tempered character. And Alvarado has brothers, and they have mates. They have a kind of faction, and their faction will pile in. They're like, great, we'll come on this voyage. It's often relatives, isn't it? It's often brothers, cousins, and so on.
是的，家庭或地区联系。因为并没有真正的指挥结构。不。不，这不是一支军队。所以这有点像不同的人聚在一起又分开。完全正确。人们总是认为这些是士兵。他们大多数不是士兵。他们没有穿盔甲。他们并不都受过训练。这是一群人，他们之间往往相当敌对，是竞争对手，但同意暂时联手试图赚点钱。
Yes, family or regional connections. Because there aren't really structures of command. No. No, this isn't an army. And so it's kind of posses of different people meeting up and splitting off. Exactly. People always think that these are soldiers. Most of them are not soldiers. They're not wearing armor. They're not all disciplined. It's a company of people who are often quite antagonistic to each other, who are rivals, but have agreed to team up temporarily to try and make some money.
所以武装企业家，马修·雷斯特尔，这一集伟大的历史学家，称他们为。完全正确。我认为这是一个很棒的短语。现在科尔特斯本人，他开始四处招摇。一旦他获得了指挥权，他就给自己买了一件漂亮的黑色天鹅绒斗篷、一枚金质奖章和一顶华丽的羽毛帽。他在古巴的码头上穿着这身行头走来走去，
So armed entrepreneurs, Matthew Restle, the great historian of this episode, calls them. Exactly. I think it's a great phrase. Now Cortez himself, he starts swanning around. As soon as he's got the command, he buys himself a nice black velvet cloak and a gold medallion and a magnificent kind of plumed hat. And he's wandering around the docks in Cuba in this getup,
就像我现在是伟大的船长一样。即使在这一点上，作为他们总督的迭戈·贝拉斯克斯，他就像，这根本不是我所期望的。实际上，有一个非凡的时刻，他的弄臣，名叫弗朗西斯科，对他说，埃尔南·科尔特斯要偷走你所有的船。贝拉斯克斯说，哈哈，他不会那样做的。我了解科尔特斯。
like I'm the great captain now. And even at this point, Diego Velazquez, who is their governor, he's like, this wasn't what I was expecting at all. And actually, there's an extraordinary moment where his jester, who's called Francisco, says to him, Hernan Cortes is going to steal all your ships. And Velazquez says, ha, ha, ha, he wouldn't do that. I know Cortes.
他什么都不是。他是个无名小卒。大约三天后，他发现弄臣也报名参加了探险队。所以他想，哦，这行不通。科尔特斯有所有的马、狗。他借了很多钱来搞定这一切。贝拉斯克斯开始变得非常紧张。这是一种松散的迹象，我想，西班牙统治的软弱，贝拉斯克斯开始变得非常紧张。这是一种松散的迹象，我想，
He's nothing. He's a nobody. About three days later, he finds the jester has signed up to the expedition as well. So he thinks, oh, this isn't working out. Cortes has got all these horses, dogs. He's borrowed loads of money to get all this. And Velazquez starts to get very nervous. And it's a sign of the looseness, I suppose, the weakness of Spanish rule, that Velazquez starts to get very nervous. And it's a sign of the looseness, I suppose,
西班牙统治的软弱，贝拉斯克斯试图取消它。他对科尔特斯说，实际上，不要去。我会找别人去。我不希望你去。无论如何都不要去。科尔特斯完全无视他。直接出发了。
the weakness of Spanish rule, that Velazquez tries to cancel it. He says to Cortés, actually, don't go. I'll get someone else to go. I don't want you to go. Under no circumstances go. Cortés completely ignores him. And just heads off.
在这个非常著名的片段中，贝拉斯克斯实际上去了码头试图阻止这一切。科尔特斯航行到远方，有点像在他的……所以那是1519年2月10日。科尔特斯正在航行。这是一个大任务。他有11艘船。
And in this very famous episode, Velazquez actually goes down to the docks to sort of shut the whole thing down. And there's Cortés sailing off into the distance by kind of on his... So that's the 10th of February, 1519. Cortes is sailing off. And it's a big mission. He's got 11 ships.
他有500人。当然，他们都去的原因是他们听说了黄金，汤姆。当然。那是主要的动机。我的意思是，基督教对他们确实很重要。我绝对不会像他们的一些批评者那样忽视这一点。我认为他们都是真正的信徒，他们真诚地认为如果我们能把人们带到上帝面前，如果我们能铲除他们的宗教并强加我们自己的宗教，我们就是在做一件非常、非常好的事情。但他们在那条船上的原因
He's got 500 men. Of course, the reason they're all going is they've heard about the gold, Tom. Of course. That's the main motivation. I mean, that Christianity does matter to them. I absolutely do not discount it, that Christianity does matter to them. I absolutely do not discount it as some of their critics do. I think they are all true believers and they genuinely think if we can bring people to God, if we can stamp out their religions and impose our own, we are doing a really, really good thing. But the reason they're on that boat
是因为他们想要冒险，他们想要荣耀，但他们也想变得富有。他们生活在氏族、亲属网络和家庭的世界里。他们认为这不仅仅是关于他们个人的财富。他们将能够把钱带回家。妈妈和爸爸会有一个漂亮的新房子。佩德罗叔叔。而且上帝可能也希望如此。是的。所有这类事情。这并不全是白人。有泰诺仆人，坦率地说，有泰诺奴隶在搬运他们的很多东西。几乎肯定有非洲奴隶。可能还有一些非洲自由民。
is because they want adventure, they want glory, but they also want to be rich. They're living in worlds of clans and kinship networks and families. And they think it's not just about their own individual wealth. They'll be able to take the money back home. Mommy and daddy will have a nice new house. Uncle Pedro. And God has willed it probably. Yeah. And all of this kind of thing. It's not all white. There are Taino servants, and frankly, there are Taino slaves who are carrying a lot of their stuff. There are almost certainly African slaves. There's probably some African freedmen.
有一个我们肯定知道。是一个叫英俊约翰的人，胡安·加里多，我想他曾被葡萄牙人奴役，最终到了西班牙。我们知道他在船上。大多数西班牙人是南方人。所以他们来自塞维利亚。有些来自埃斯特雷马杜拉，就像科尔特斯本人一样。正如我所说，他们不是士兵。
There's one we definitely know about. It was a guy called Handsome John, Juan Garrido, who I think had been enslaved by the Portuguese and had ended up in Spain. And we know he was on the ships with them. Most of the Spaniards are Southerners. So they're from Seville. Some are from extra-majora like Cortes himself. As I said, they're not soldiers.
人们做了这项了不起的工作，分析了征服者的背景。他们是工匠。他们是铁匠、木匠。所以他们是有技能的人，但有抱负。对。去寻求更好的生活。想要成为伊达尔戈。想要成为那种走出去夺取自己财富的人。
People have done this amazing work analyzing the backgrounds of the conquistadors. They're artisans. They're blacksmiths, carpenters. So they're people with skills, but who are aspirational. Right. Who've gone to seek a better life. Who want to become Hidalgos. Who want to become the kind of people who go out and seize their own fortunes.
是的，完全正确。而且他们并不都团结在科尔特斯身后。我认为这非常重要。科尔特斯处于一个不安全的位置。他以前从未指挥过公司。这可能就是为什么他买了这顶荒谬的帽子，因为他想给每个人留下深刻印象。他需要证明他是一名船长。而且有不同的派系。所以那些船上的一些人实际上非常忠于总督。他们由一个叫弗朗西斯科·德·蒙特霍的人领导，
Yes, exactly. And they're not all united behind Cortes. I think that's really important. Cortes is in an insecure position. He's never commanded a company before. That's probably why he's bought this ridiculous hat, because he wants to impress everybody. He needs to prove that he's a captain. And there were different factions. So there are some of those people on those ships are actually very loyal to the governor. And they're led by a guy called Francisco de Montejo,
我们稍后会提到他。然后是阿尔瓦拉多一家。他可能认为阿尔瓦拉多一家是非常无情的人。他们基本上就像黑帮。如果我不小心，他们可能会在背后捅我一刀，把我扔进海里。所以我需要让他们站在我这边。所以他们有装满所有他们要和当地人交换的东西的箱子。他们预料到会有一场战斗。所以他们都有剑，他们有一些大炮，他们有一些枪。很多人认为，你经常会在那些针对机场书店里CEO的流行历史书中读到，火药、火力是西班牙人拥有而阿兹特克人没有的关键东西。我认为这完全错了。
who we'll mention a bit later on. And then there's the Alvarados. And he probably thinks the Alvarados are very ruthless men. They're like gangsters basically. If I'm not careful, they'll probably stab me in the back and throw me overboard. So I need to keep them on side. So they've got chests full of all the stuff they're going to swap with the locals. They expect a fight. So they've all got swords, they've got some cannons and they've got some guns. A lot of people think, you will often read this in those sort of popular history books that are aimed at CEOs in airport bookshops, that gunpowder, firepower is the key thing that the Spanish have that the Aztecs don't. I think that's quite wrong. The
大炮实际上相当无用。它们擅长吓唬人，但它们太麻烦了，会在你脸上爆炸，火药会变湿。嗯，故事中有一个关键时刻，如果仅仅面对一大群袭击者，它们是有用的。是的。因为那时它有点像霰弹。你无法瞄准，但一大群沸腾的人群，你发射一门大炮，那么效果是致命的。但你的关键武器是剑。那是西班牙人拥有而当地人没有的关键技术优势。他们有托莱多剑，在欧洲很有名，非常轻的钢剑。你可以造成很大的伤害。一个拿着剑的西班牙人可以击退很多拿着棍棒的土著。那马呢？是的，他们确实有马，汤姆。他们有16匹马。现在，美洲没有马。毫无例外，当人们看到马时，他们都吓坏了。
cannons are actually quite useless. They're good at scaring people, but they're so fiddly, they explode in your face, the gunpowder gets wet. Well, there's a key moment in the story to come where they are useful if you were just faced with an enormous pack of assailants. Yes. Because then it's kind of the grape shot. You can't aim, but a vast seething mass of people and you fire a cannon, then the effects are lethal. But your key weapon is the sword. That is the key technological advantage the Spanish have that the locals don't. They have Toledo swords, which are renowned in Europe, very light steel swords. You can do an awful lot of damage. One Spaniard with a sword can see off an awful lot of natives with clubs. And what about horses? Yes, they do have horses, Tom. They have 16 horses. Now, there are no horses in the Americas. And without exception, when people see the horses, they are terrified.
这些是什么生物？可怕的、巨大的鹿。他们有马，他们也有猎狼犬。同样，人们对狗感到恐惧。我们的制片人西奥简直不敢相信。阿兹特克人甚至没有剑。他说他们没有剑。他们有黑色的火山玻璃黑曜石刀片，或者他们有镶嵌着玻璃碎片的棍棒，但他们没有剑。嗯，所以卡米拉·汤森在她那本精彩的《第五子》中，我们有充分的理由提到它，她对此说，这几乎就像文艺复兴时期的欧洲与古代苏美尔人面对面一样。是的，西班牙人带着比美洲人多出几千年的农业优势而来，因此因为农业，他们能够构建
What are these creatures? Terrifying, gigantic deer. They have horses and they also have wolfhounds. Again, people are terrified of the dogs. Theo, our producer, is just in disbelief. The Aztecs don't even have swords. He says they didn't have swords. They had black volcanic glass obsidian blades, or they had clubs studded with shards of glass, but they didn't have swords. Well, so Camilla Townsend in her wonderful book, Fifth Son, which we've had plenty of reason to mention, she says about this that it was almost as if Renaissance Europe had come face to face with the ancient sumerians yes that the spanish come with the advantage of many many thousands of years more of agriculture than people in the americas and therefore because of agriculture they have been able to construct what
我们称之为文明的东西，我想。是的，他们在和平和战争的各种艺术中都更精通，不是因为智力上的任何差异或类似的东西，而仅仅是因为他们因为旧大陆拥有的植物和动物而领先，而新大陆没有。完全正确，完全正确。他们带着一系列阿兹特克人没有的资产而来。他们有马，他们有狗，他们有剑。当然，后来他们会有轮子。他们有船。他们有船，对。我的意思是，船是至关重要的东西
we would call civilization i guess yeah they are more proficient in all the various arts of peace and, of course, of war, not because of any difference in intelligence or anything like that, but simply because they have the head start because of the benefits of the plants and the animals that they have in the old world that the new world don't have. Exactly, exactly. They've come with a whole series of assets that the Aztecs don't have. They have the horses, they have the dogs, they have swords. Of course, later on, they'll have wheels. And they have the ships. They have ships, right. I mean, the ships are the crucial thing
因为船太大了，他们可以带来越来越多的人。而且这，再次，我认为是故事的重要部分。它是。也许是蒙特祖马担心的事情。还有一件事，当然，他们有，汤姆。他们随身携带，不是现在，但他们会在以后的剧集中，
because the ships are so huge that they can bring more and more people. And this, again, I think is a massive part of the story. It is. Perhaps of what Motsuma is worrying about. And one more thing, of course, they have, Tom. They are bringing with them, not at this point, but they will do in future episodes,
他们带来了一种生物武器。他们无意中带来了病毒。你提到的天花。那将对新大陆的人民造成巨大的伤害。所以他们出发了，他们的第一件事是登陆科苏梅尔，一个非常受欢迎的岛屿，正如我上次所说，潜水员喜欢。他们沿着胡安·德·格里哈尔瓦的路径。他们到达那里，科尔特斯从一开始。他对寺庙里的偶像和祭祀的迹象感到震惊，或者他说他感到震惊。他让他的手下把
they're bringing a biological weapon. They're bringing viruses, unwittingly. The smallpox that you mentioned. That will cause enormous damage to the peoples of the New World. So they set off, and their first thing is they land on Cozumel, a very popular island, as I said last time, with divers. They're following the path of Juan de Grialva. They arrive there, Cortes from the beginning. He's shocked, or he says he's shocked, by the temples with the idols and with the signs of sacrifice. He gets his men to roll
偶像从这些寺庙的台阶上滚下来，并竖起圣母玛利亚的雕像。我认为我们没有理由相信那不是真的。我们知道当地人对此有何反应吗？当地人据说对此感到不安，但他们很害怕。这些家伙带着他们从未见过的武器来了。他对他们说，你们必须停止活人祭祀。你们必须接受基督。他们有点顺从了，或者他们假装顺从。我的意思是，他们做什么很明显。他们只是说，当然，我们当然会。
the idols down the steps of these temples and put up an effigy of the Virgin Mary. There's no reason for us, I would say, to believe that that's not true. Do we know how this goes down with the locals? The locals are supposedly perturbed by this, but they're terrified. There's these blokes coming with weapons that they have never seen before. He says to them, you must stop human sacrifices. You must accept Christ. And they sort of go along with it, or they pretend to. I mean, it's obvious what they do. They just say, sure, of course we will.
然后他们基本上等到西班牙人转过身去。然而，在这一点上，发生了一件非常奇特和非凡的事情。当地人是玛雅人，他们说，大陆上的家伙，顺便说一下，他们是食人族，他们有一个白人，一个像你们一样的人，一个基督徒。西班牙人无法相信这一点。他们派了一艘船到大陆，带信说，有这样的人吗？他应该表明身份，我们会带他回来。他们什么也没听到。他们回去，正要出发进行航行的下一部分。在一个好莱坞式的转折中，汤姆，他们
And then they basically wait until the Spaniards have turned their backs. However, at this point, something very peculiar and extraordinary happens. The locals who are Maya, they say, the fellas on the mainland, who are cannibals, by the way, they have a white man with them, a man like you, a Christian. And the Spanish can't believe this. They send a ship over to the mainland with a message to say, is there such a person? He should declare himself and we'll take him back. And they hear nothing. They go back and they're just about to set off and do the next part of their voyage. And in a sort of Hollywood twist, Tom, they're
在海滩上做弥撒。他们在海滩上做弥撒。然后他们正要上船时，看到这艘独木舟带着几个棕色皮肤的玛雅人和一个留着大胡子、看起来像鲁滨逊·克鲁索的白皮肤男人到达。这个家伙显然踉踉跄跄地向他们走来。他用西班牙语说，先生们，你们真的是基督徒吗？你们是谁？令人难以置信的是，他是一个白人基督徒。这是一个了不起的故事，一个了不起的故事。他叫赫罗尼莫·德·阿吉拉尔。他来自
having mass on the beach. They have mass on the beach. And then they're just about to get into their ships when they see this canoe arriving with a couple of brown-skinned Mayans and a white-skinned man with a massive beard who looks like Robinson Crusoe. And this bloke apparently staggers up the beach towards them. And he says in Spanish, gentlemen, are you truly Christians? Who are you? And unbelievably, it is a white Christian man. And this is an amazing story, an amazing story. He's called Geronimo de Aguilar. He came from
塞维利亚。他是一名修士。他十年前来到新大陆。他在牙买加附近和他的同事们一起遭遇海难。他们最终乘划艇逃脱，被潮汐带走，冲到了尤卡坦半岛的海岸。在那里，他们被当地人俘虏，正如科苏梅尔的人所说，当地人确实有吃人肉的嗜好，或者看起来有。当地人吃掉了一些西班牙人。这都是根据阿吉拉尔的说法。他们把剩下的人关在笼子里，阿吉拉尔和其他人对自己说，基督，
this Seville. He was a friar. He'd come to the New World a decade earlier. He'd been shipwrecked off Jamaica with a load of his colleagues. They had ended up escaping in a rowing boat and they'd been carried off by the tide and they'd washed up on the coast of the Yucatan Peninsula. There they were captured by the locals who, just as the people in Cozumel said, did have a taste for human flesh or appear to have done. The locals ate some of the Spaniards. This is all according to Aguilar. They put the rest in these cages and Aguilar and the others said to themselves, Christ,
我们在一个巨大的储藏室里。他们要把我们养肥了作为未来的食物。所以他们从笼子里逃了出来。他们被另一个玛雅酋长俘虏，他不是食人族。顺便说一下，这都是阿吉拉尔的说法。我的意思是——是的。所以我们不知道它有多真实。有多少是真的，我们不知道。他们被另一个家伙俘虏了。他把他们当作奴隶活着。他们大多数人死于疾病，或者仅仅是绝望，但有两个人没有，一个是阿吉拉尔，还有一个叫贡萨洛·格雷罗。阿吉拉尔显然因为他是修士，每天对自己喃喃自语祈祷，提醒自己是谁，他声称玛雅人
we're in a massive larder. They're going to fatten us up for future meals. So they broke out of the cages. They escaped. They were captured by another Maya chieftain who was not a cannibal. By the way, this is all Aguilar's account. I mean- Yeah. So we don't know how true it is. How much of this is true, we do not know. They're captured by this other bloke. He kept them alive as slaves. Most of them died of disease, or just terminal depression but two of them didn't one is aguilar and there's a guy called gonzalo guerrero aguilar apparently because he's a friar he mutters prayers to himself every day to remind himself who he is and he claimed that the mayans
我的意思是这在很大程度上是一个投射问题，我怀疑，汤姆。他声称玛雅人不断给他送来年轻、半裸的女人来诱惑他，但他意志坚定，记得耶稣，能够坚持住。这对贡萨洛·格雷罗来说不是真的。他，用一个殖民术语来说，完全本土化了。他最终成为了一个叫纳·钱·坎的军阀的首席军事顾问。他娶了一个玛雅女人。他有了玛雅孩子。他纹了脸。
i mean this is very much a projection issue i I suspect, Tom. He claimed that the Mayans kept sending him nubile, half-naked women to tempt him, but that he was so strong-willed that he remembered Jesus and was able to hold out. This is not true of Gonzalo Guerrero. He, to use a colonial term, went completely native. He ended up becoming the chief military advisor to a warlord called Na Chan Can. He married a Mayan woman. He had Mayan kids. He tattooed his face.
有耳塞和所有的东西。他脸上塞满了塞子。总之，他们都收到了科尔特斯的消息。你知道，如果大陆上有欧洲人，我们就在这里。我们来救你们了。阿吉拉尔去见格雷罗，说，这是我们的机会。格雷罗显然说，不，我陷得太深了。你知道，我有塞子。
Had the plugs and all the works. He had all the plugs in his face. Anyway, they both got this message from Cortez. You know, if there are Europeans on the mainland, here we are. We've come to rescue you. Aguilar went to see Guerra and said, this is our chance. Guerra apparently said, no, I'm too far gone. You know, I've got the plugs.
我有纹身。他结婚了，是吗？他有孩子。孩子。是的。他有三个儿子。他说，我不去。我不去。
I've got the tattoos. He's married, is he? He's got kids. Children. Yeah. He had three sons. He said, I'm not going. I'm not going.
他没有去。令人惊奇的是，他继续担任玛雅人的亨利·基辛格式的顾问。他后来实际上还与西班牙人作战。他在六十多岁时死于与西班牙人的战斗。他在六十多岁时死于与西班牙人的战斗。多么了不起的一生。了不起的一生，是的。阿吉拉尔，他确实去了。所以他划船去见科尔特斯。所以他大概能说当地语言。这太重要了。这太重要了。因为现在第一次，西班牙人带了一个能说一种美洲原住民语言的西班牙人。
And he didn't go. And the amazing thing is, he continued in his post as kind of the Henry Kissinger of sort of advisor to the Mayans. And he actually ended up fighting against the Spaniards later on. He died in his mid-sixties fighting the Spaniards later on. He died in his mid-sixties fighting the Spaniards. What an amazing life. Amazing life, yes. Aguilar, he did go. So he's paddled over to see Cortes. And so he can presumably speak the local language. This is massive. This is massive. Because now for the first time, the Spaniards have a Spaniard with them who can speak one of the Mesoamerican languages.
所以阿吉拉尔是科尔特斯的一笔巨大资产。接下来发生的是科尔特斯得到了另一笔资产，这笔资产对他来说更重要，可以说，汤姆，你可以提出一个理由。历史上最顶尖的情妇。不仅仅是顶尖的情妇。我认为她是史上最重要两三位女性之一。好的。那么我们现在休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将谈论一位在万神殿中排名
So Aguilar is a massive asset to Cortes. And what happens next is Cortes gets another asset who is even more important to his, arguably, Tom, you could make a case. The top mistress in history. Not just the top mistress. I would argue she's one of the two or three most important women of all time. Okay. So let's take a break now. And when we come back, we will talk about a woman who ranks in the pantheon
史上最重要女性之一的女性。多米尼克，我完全同意你的看法。天哪。汤姆，这太令人兴奋了。是的。不，她是一位在我们要讲述的不可思议的戏剧中角色极其、极其重要的女性。这也是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先观看现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
of the most important women of all time. And Dominic, I completely agree with you. Crikey. Tom, this is exciting. Yeah. No, she's a woman whose role is hugely, hugely important in the incredible drama of what we are about to narrate. So's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。多米尼克，到目前为止，在这个故事中我们有很多男人，我们没有很多女人。但让我们来谈谈这位后来被称为“拉·马林切”的非凡女性，但这不是她原来的名字。她是谁？她是怎么落入科尔特斯手中的？故事是什么？所以拉·马林切，正如她所知，在墨西哥海岸的夸察夸尔科斯省长大。她的父亲在他们的村子里曾是一个当地的大人物。他们说和阿兹特克人一样的语言，但他们不是阿兹特克人。他们不是墨西加人。她在种族上是纳瓦人。她父亲在她年轻时去世，她母亲再婚了。在那之后不久，这个最终被称为“拉·马林切”的女孩被带到了海岸，也许是违背了她
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We've had a lot of men up till now, Dominic, in this story, and we haven't had many women. But let's come on to this extraordinary woman who comes to be known as La Melinche, but not her original name. Who is she? How does she kind of fall into the hands of Cortez? What's the story? So La Malinche, as she is known, had grown up on the coast of Mexico in the province of Coatzacoalcos. And her father had been a kind of local bigwig in their village. They spoke the same language as the Aztecs, but they weren't Aztecs. They weren't Mexica. She's a Nahua, ethnically. Her father died when she was young, and her mother married again. And sometime after that, the girl who ends up being known as La Melinche was taken to the coast, perhaps against her
母亲的意愿，或者是由她母亲带走的，没人知道。她被放进一艘独木舟，他们划走了，她实际上被卖为奴隶，进入了玛雅奴隶制。她最终在不同的主人、不同的领主之间辗转。最终她可能处于十几岁到二十岁出头。我们不可能知道。我们甚至不知道她的名字。她最终在一个叫波通钱的玛雅贸易城镇，这是一个大型奴隶贸易和一般市场城镇。它在河上。它在雨林里。所以人们可以想象它。
mother's will, or by her mother, or no one knows. She was put in a canoe and they paddled off and she was effectively sold into slavery, into Mayan slavery. She ended up moving between different owners, different lords, I guess. And eventually she ends up probably in her mid to late teens. It's impossible for us to know. We don't even know her name. She ends up in a Maya trading town called Potonchan, which is a big slave trading and general kind of market town. It's up river. It's in the rainforest. So people can picture it.
那里的人住在土坯房里。所以小屋有某种夯土，屋顶是茅草。在波通钱，她可能是成百上千名奴隶中的一个。有一天，他们看到这些巨大的木制装置顺流而上。这些是西班牙船只。所以西班牙人沿着海岸来了。科尔特斯沿着海岸来了，招募了阿吉拉尔作为翻译。他们来到了现在的塔巴斯科州，他们转入河道，深入内陆，因为他们听到了关于一个城镇的报告。镇民最初欢迎西班牙人，然后他们与他们闹翻了。
People there live in adobe huts. So huts have kind of beaten mud with thatched roofs. And in Potonchan, she is probably one of hundreds and thousands of slaves. And one day, they see these huge wooden contraptions coming up the river. These are the Spanish ships. So the Spanish have come up the coast. Cortes has come up the coast, having recruited Aguilar as an interpreter. They've come to the state of what is now Tabasco, and they've turned up river and come inland because they've heard reports of a town. The townsfolk initially welcome the Spaniards, then they fall out with them.
这通常是这样的方式。是因为西班牙人越界了吗？谁知道呢。西班牙人使用他们的大炮和马匹，所以我们上半部分提到的两件事，汤姆，来吓唬他们，基本上击败他们。玛雅人似乎特别害怕马。基本上，玛雅人同意屈服，他们做了两件非常重要的事情，因为其他人以后也会做同样的事情。第一，他们说他们会拥抱基督，放弃他们当地的神，拥抱基督。你可以想象他们做出那个承诺是多么真诚。他们做出的另一个承诺是他们会承认西班牙国王是他们的领主。那毫无意义，不是吗？
This is so often the way. Is that because the Spanish have overstepped the mark? Who knows? The Spanish use their cannon and their horses, so two of the things we mentioned in the first half, Tom, to scare them, to defeat them, basically. The Maya seem to be particularly frightened of the horses. Basically, the Maya agree to give in, and they do two things that are really important because other people will do the same later on. Number one, they say they will embrace Christ, give up their local gods and embrace Christ. You can imagine just how sincerely they're making that promise. And the other promise they're making is they will acknowledge the king of Spain as their overlord. That's meaningless, isn't it?
当然。是的。他们不知道他在哪里，他是谁。他们只会说任何能让这些留着胡子的闯入者离开的话。可怕的入侵者，是的。是的。他们给了他们大量的食物。他们对他们说，因为西班牙人当然在说，你们有黄金吗？
Of course. Yeah. They don't know where he is, who he is. They'll just say whatever it takes to make these bearded interlopers go away. Terrifying intruders, yeah. Yeah. They give them loads of food. They say to them, because the Spanish, of course, are saying, do you have gold?
他们说，没有。但路那边的家伙，当然在说，你们有黄金吗？他们说，没有。但路那边的家伙，他们有。他们有很多黄金。去问他们。可能就在那一刻，埃尔南·科尔特斯第一次听到了这个词，墨西加人，墨西哥谷的人民。他们有很多黄金。你应该去找到他们。
And they say, no. But the guys down the road, they course, are saying, do you have gold? And they say, no. But the guys down the road, they have. They have loads of gold. Go and ask them. It's probably at that moment that Hernan Cortes first hears the word, the Mexica, the people of the Valley of Mexico. They have loads of gold. You should go and find out them.
现在，波通钱的人说，你们去吧，走吧，你们会在海岸上找到很多黄金。我们会给你们20个奴隶女孩，因为你们想要女性陪伴来做饭和打扫，也是性奴隶。拉·马林切是送给西班牙人的这20个年轻女性或十几岁女孩中的一个。她们都受了洗，都被起了西班牙名字，但我认为不需要太多想象力就能推测她们中的许多人并没有得到很好的对待。现在，起初，她并没有非常突出，但西班牙人带着奴隶，带着他们从这个城镇收集的食物再次出发。他们沿着海岸走，在复活节前三天，他们到达了祭祀岛，
Now, the people of Potonchan say, you go, go off, you'll find loads of gold up the coast. We will give you 20 slave girls, because you want female company to cook and clean and are sex slaves as well. And La Melinche is one of these 20 young women or teenage girls who are given to the Spanish. They're all baptized and they're all given Spanish names, but I don't think it takes much imagination to suppose that many of them are not very well treated. Now, at first, she doesn't massively stand out, but the Spanish set off again with the slaves, with the food they've collected from this town. They go up the coast and three days before Easter, they reach the Isle of Sacrifices,
现在，波通钱的人说，你们走吧，离开这里，你们会沿着海岸找到大量的黄金。我们会给你们20个女奴，因为你们需要女性陪伴来做饭、打扫，她们也是性奴。拉·马林切就是这20名被送给西班牙人的年轻女性或少女之一。她们都受了洗，也都有了西班牙名字，但我认为不需要太多的想象力就能推测出，她们中的许多人并没有得到很好的对待。起初，她并没有特别引人注目，但西班牙人带着奴隶和从这个城镇收集的食物再次出发了。他们沿着海岸北上，在复活节前三天，他们到达了祭祀岛，
which is where Juan de Grialba had found pyramids littered with skulls. And they're there, they're based there. And some people paddle over from the mainland. These are the Totonacs who had- The guys who'd been so friendly before. Been so friendly before. And Cortes says to Geronimo de Aguilar, come on then, do your stuff. And the Totonacs start speaking and Aguilar, come on then, do your stuff. And the Tottenhacks start speaking.
也就是胡安·德·格里哈尔瓦发现金字塔上堆满头骨的地方。他们就在那里，以那里为基地。有些人从大陆划船过来。这些人是托托纳克人，就是之前非常友好的人。之前非常友好。科尔特斯对赫罗尼莫·德·阿吉拉尔说，来吧，展示你的本事。托托纳克人开始说话，阿吉拉尔，来吧，展示你的本事。托托纳克人开始说话。
And Aguilar's face kind of turns white with terror because he doesn't understand a word they're saying because he only speaks Mayan. And it's at that point that this girl steps forward and she says to Aguilar in Mayan, this is fine. I understand what they're saying because they are Nawaz like me. They speak Nahuatl and I can say it to you and you can then translate it into Spanish. And this becomes this chain of communication that is so important because everything the Totonacs are saying, she translates into Mayan and Aguilar can translate it into Spanish. And over time, what seems to have happened is that actually Aguilar can translate it into Spanish. And over time, what seems to
阿吉拉尔的脸因为恐惧而变得苍白，因为他一个字也听不懂，他只会说玛雅语。就在这时，这个女孩走上前来，用玛雅语对阿吉拉尔说，没关系。我听得懂他们在说什么，因为他们和我一样是纳瓦人。他们说纳瓦特尔语，我可以告诉你，然后你再把它翻译成西班牙语。这形成了一条至关重要的交流链，因为托托纳克人说的每一句话，她都翻译成玛雅语，阿吉拉尔再翻译成西班牙语。随着时间的推移，似乎发生的情况是，实际上阿吉拉尔可以把它翻译成西班牙语。随着时间的推移，似乎
have happened is that actually Aguilar becomes redundant because it must've taken quite a long time, but she learns Spanish. Because she proves to have an incredible facility for languages. So she's obviously picked up Mayan and she picks up Spanish very, very soon. And this for Cortes is the most incredible piece of luck, isn't it? Because without this, he simply cannot understand the world that he's entering. Yeah. People may, listening to this, think, so what? It's just an interpreter. They're massively overstating this.
发生的情况是，实际上阿吉拉尔变得多余了，因为这一定花了不少时间，但她学会了西班牙语。因为她证明了自己具有惊人的语言天赋。所以她显然学会了玛雅语，而且很快就学会了西班牙语。对于科尔特斯来说，这真是不可思议的好运，不是吗？因为没有这个，他根本无法理解他所进入的世界。是的。听众听到这里可能会想，那又怎样？这只是个翻译。他们太夸大其词了。
It is absolutely crucial. And the best historians of the conquest, so people like we mentioned Camilla Townsend or Matthew Restle, they really emphasize this because it's not just saying what people are saying. It is that, as you said, it's like they've landed on an alien planet and they don't understand anything. They don't have a universal translator, so they need to find one. I mean, Captain Kirk landing on the planet, he has to be able to speak to the aliens. That's the whole gimmick. But if he doesn't, then... But it's not just understanding what the aliens are saying. It's they need somebody who would explain to them, who are the gods? What is the expected ritual here? When you meet a dignitary
这绝对是至关重要的。征服史最好的历史学家，比如我们提到的卡米拉·汤森或马修·雷斯特尔，他们确实强调了这一点，因为这不仅仅是转述人们说的话。正如你所说，这就像他们降落在一个外星行星上，什么都不懂。他们没有万能翻译机，所以他们必须找到一个。我的意思是，柯克船长降落在行星上，他必须能够与外星人交谈。这就是整个噱头。但如果他不能，那么……但这不仅仅是理解外星人在说什么。他们需要有人向他们解释，谁是神？这里有什么预期的仪式？当你遇到一个来自
from this particular town, do you bow or do you kneel or what do you do? They don't know anything and she has to explain everything to them. But more than that, to the Spaniards, all these Indians, as they call them, are presumably indistinguishable. But in fact, of course, they're not because they all speak different languages. They come from different cultures and lots of them are hostile to each other. So I would say another crucial part role that La Malinche pays is that she detests the Mexica. She really detests them because they are the ones who have sold her into slavery. All the horrors that have been visited on her since childhood, she blames on the Mexica and she is now Cortez's right-hand woman. So must be playing a crucial role in encouraging him to do it.
这个特定城镇的显贵时，你是鞠躬还是下跪，或者你该怎么做？他们什么都不知道，她必须向他们解释一切。但更重要的是，对西班牙人来说，所有这些他们所谓的印第安人大概都是无法区分的。但事实上，当然不是，因为他们都说不同的语言。他们来自不同的文化，而且他们中很多人彼此敌对。所以我认为拉马林切扮演的另一个关键角色是她憎恨墨西加人。她真的很憎恨他们，因为是他们把她卖为奴隶。自童年以来她所遭受的所有恐怖，她都归咎于墨西加人，而她现在是科尔特斯的得力助手。所以她一定在鼓励他这样做方面发挥了关键作用。
And I would guess furthermore, also further down the line, when in due course she comes to meet with Moctezuma and talk to people in Tenochtitlan, is that she's seen these ships. So she knows that there are these structures that can cross the sea and presumably can bring infinite numbers more of the Spaniards. So she better probably than anyone else in America, the native peoples in America has an understanding of what the Spaniards represent. Yeah. It's not just a few isolated, you know, 200 men, 300 men, whatever. It's vast fleets, vast teeming numbers of people, all armed with steel and cannon and dogs and horses.
而且我猜，更进一步说，当她后来有机会见到蒙特祖马并与特诺奇蒂特兰的人交谈时，她见过这些船。所以她知道有这些可以横渡大海的结构，大概还能带来无穷无尽的西班牙人。所以她可能比美国任何其他原住民都更了解西班牙人代表什么。是的。这不仅仅是几个孤立的，你知道，200人，300人，不管多少。这是庞大的舰队，庞大的人群，全都装备着钢铁、大炮、狗和马。
So she knows what's coming. There are so many interesting elements of this, Tom. First of all, La Melinche, she's much younger than Cortez. She ends up, big spoiler alert, she will end up bearing him a child some historians i mean so the tradition in mexico is to see her as the great betrayer the sex crazed kind of traitor who sells out her own people of course she doesn't see it as selling out her own people she hates them but they're not her people are they no yeah exactly exactly exactly more recently the trend has been to see her as
所以她知道即将发生什么。汤姆，这里面有很多有趣的元素。首先，拉马林切，她比科尔特斯年轻得多。最后，剧透预警，她最终会为他生下一个孩子。我的意思是，墨西哥的传统是将她视为伟大的背叛者，那个出卖自己人民的性欲狂叛徒。当然，她并不认为这是出卖自己的人民，她憎恨他们，但他们不是她的人民，对吧？不，是的，完全正确，完全正确。最近的趋势是将她视为
a kind of a victim, as somebody who was sold into slavery, as somebody who became Cortez's plaything, Cortez's sex slave. But of course, another way of looking at this, another dimension, I'm not saying one of them is right and the other is wrong. They may be both true, is that she has agency herself. Well, she's manipulating Cortez. Manipulating him. That's the fascinating thing because everything Cortes later writes to Charles V, the King of Spain, everything that he says about what has happened, he is repeating what she has told him because he doesn't speak the language. But also, Dominic, an intriguing absence is that he doesn't dwell on her. He doesn't mention her. He will say occasionally that he has a translator because otherwise the letters he's writing back to the Spanish king are wholly implausible because he has to have a translator.
一种受害者，一个被卖为奴隶的人，一个成为科尔特斯玩物、科尔特斯性奴的人。但当然，看待这件事的另一种方式，另一个维度，我并不是说其中一个是对的，另一个是错的。它们可能都是真的，那就是她自己有能动性。嗯，她在操纵科尔特斯。操纵他。这才是最迷人的地方，因为科尔特斯后来写给西班牙国王查理五世的所有信件，他所说的关于发生的一切，都是在重复她告诉他的话，因为他不会说那种语言。但多米尼克，一个耐人寻味的缺失是，他并没有过多谈论她。他没有提到她。他偶尔会说他有一个翻译，因为否则他写给西班牙国王的信就完全不可信了，因为他必须有一个翻译。
But he understands what he has in Malinche, but he does kind of resent it as well, doesn't he? He does, I think so. And particularly in due course when the native people that he's coming up against start calling him Malinche. Well, here's the fascinating thing. So in the chronicles and the painted books, she often is there. She's often a figure in the native people's recollections of what happened. They pay a lot of attention to her because she's such an extraordinary figure to
但他明白他在马林切身上拥有什么，但他确实也对此感到不满，不是吗？我想是的。特别是在后来，当他遇到的原住民开始称他为马林切时。嗯，这就是最迷人的地方。所以在编年史和绘本中，她经常出现。在原住民对所发生之事的记忆中，她经常是一个人物。他们非常关注她，因为她是一个如此非凡的人物，对
them. Imagine that scene that we started the whole series with, Tom, the Spaniards coming down the causeway. They're going to meet the Aztecs for the first time. It's the Spaniards. And standing next to Cortes is a Nahuatl-speaking, brown-skinned, native young woman who must seem really weird to Montezuma and his courtiers. And the thing is, as you rightly say, they also, in their accounts, call Cortes Malinche. They've confused the two characters. And he's aware of this and resentful of it. So what we cannot know as historians is in these negotiations, as you say, it's a bit
他们来说。想象一下我们整个系列开始时的那个场景，汤姆，西班牙人沿着堤道走下来。他们第一次要见阿兹特克人。是西班牙人。站在科尔特斯旁边的是一个说纳瓦特尔语、棕色皮肤的年轻原住民女性，这对蒙特祖马和他的朝臣来说一定显得非常奇怪。问题是，正如你正确指出的那样，他们在叙述中也称科尔特斯为马林切。他们混淆了这两个角色。他意识到了这一点，并对此感到不满。所以作为历史学家，我们无法知道的是，在这些谈判中，正如你所说，这有点
like an alien landed in Europe in the 30 Years' War. The alien, they might look like all the people are the same. They all believe in the same God. They're all basically the same people. But of course, the alien would need someone to explain that actually the Swedes hate the French. Or it's like if an alien landed now and was trying to make sense of the Russians and the Ukrainians. Right. Yeah. But how much is Malinche twisting everything that is happening? She's doing all the deal-making. She has to be in all the negotiations. She's the person who has to relay all Cortes' offers. think that the Spaniards, even though they are massively outnumbered, that they are worth
像一个外星人降落在三十年战争时期的欧洲。外星人可能看起来所有人都一样。他们都信仰同一个上帝。他们基本上都是同一种人。但当然，外星人需要有人解释说，实际上瑞典人讨厌法国人。或者就像现在一个外星人降落并试图理解俄罗斯人和乌克兰人一样。对。是的。但马林切在多大程度上扭曲了正在发生的一切？她在进行所有的交易。她必须参与所有的谈判。她是必须传达科尔特斯所有提议的人。认为西班牙人，尽管人数处于绝对劣势，但他们值得
investing in and that they may well be able to play the role that she wants them to play because she knows that there are more of them to come. And I would say that those are the two aspects that are kind of crucial to understanding what Cortes does, but also in the long run, what Moctezuma does. Yeah. And also, crucially, Cortés' allies, because this actually doesn't end up being a battle between Cortés versus the Aztecs. It's Cortés and lots of other native peoples against the Aztecs, which is a fascinating element.
投资，而且他们很可能能够扮演她希望他们扮演的角色，因为她知道会有更多的人到来。我会说这是理解科尔特斯所作所为的两个关键方面，对于长期来看蒙特祖马的所作所为也是如此。是的。而且，至关重要的是，科尔特斯的盟友，因为这最终并没有演变成科尔特斯与阿兹特克人之间的战斗。而是科尔特斯和许多其他原住民对抗阿兹特克人，这是一个迷人的元素。
And Malinche is crucial in that, in doing all the diplomacy. Okay, so we've set her up. Cortés is still chatting to the Totonacs through her, and they seem to get on brilliantly with Cortes. They seem to have gone on generally very well with the Spaniards. They're friendly to them. They might well be frightened. We don't know. They give them beans and bits of Turkey and tortillas and all this stuff. Cortes is now on the shore. He's on the coast. He's done the one thing actually that Velazquez told him not to do, which is gone to the mainland. He's sleeping on the mainland. And on Easter Sunday, another
而马林切在外交方面至关重要。好了，我们已经铺垫好了。科尔特斯仍然通过她与托托纳克人交谈，他们似乎与科尔特斯相处得非常融洽。他们似乎与西班牙人相处得非常好。他们对他们很友好。他们很可能感到害怕。我们不知道。他们给他们豆子、火鸡肉、玉米饼和所有这些东西。科尔特斯现在在岸上。他在海岸上。他实际上做了维拉斯奎兹告诉他不要做的一件事，那就是去了大陆。他睡在大陆上。在复活节周日，又一件
extraordinary thing happens. These blokes turn up on the shore who are not Totonacs. They're dressed in very fancy cloaks and feathered headdresses. These people are the representatives of the Mexica, of the Aztecs. And they're led by a guy who the different versions of his name, but let's call him Tendile. He says, I'm the emperor's kind of regional governor. I'm the regional bigwig. And he says to Cortes, the emperor miles inland in this city they haven't seen or anything, but they've heard rumors of it. The emperor is delighted that you've come.
非凡的事情发生了。这些家伙出现在岸上，他们不是托托纳克人。他们穿着非常华丽的斗篷和羽毛头饰。这些人是墨西加人，即阿兹特克人的代表。他们由一个名字有不同版本的人领导，但我们称他为滕迪莱。他说，我是皇帝的区域总督。我是区域大人物。他对科尔特斯说，皇帝在内陆几英里外的这座城市，他们还没见过，但听说过传闻。皇帝很高兴你们来了。
Very pleased to welcome you. Very great news. We've got you lots of nice gifts emperor is delighted that you've come very pleased to welcome you very great news we've got you lots of nice gifts we've got you some gold and some feathers cortez is very pleased this is what he was hoping for he gives tendila a coat and a chair gives him an armchair bizarrely and and some beads and the count we have says that tendila regarded these presents with absolute contempt i have no need for an armchair, whatever. And he says to them, we'll build you a camp on the shore. Cortes says, oh, great, lovely. Cortes then organizes two demonstrations.
非常高兴欢迎你们。非常好的消息。我们给你们准备了很多精美的礼物，皇帝很高兴你们来了，非常高兴欢迎你们，非常好的消息，我们给你们准备了很多精美的礼物，我们给你们带来了一些黄金和羽毛。科尔特斯非常高兴，这就是他所希望的。他给了滕迪莱一件外套和一把椅子，奇怪的是还有一把扶手椅和一些珠子。我们得到的叙述说，滕迪莱对这些礼物表现出绝对的蔑视，我不需要什么扶手椅之类的。他对他们说，我们会为你们在岸上建一个营地。科尔特斯说，哦，太好了，可爱。科尔特斯随后组织了两次展示。
One, very pleasingly for you, Tom, is a demonstration of Christianity. So they set up a cross and he and his men all say their prayers. And you can imagine the scene. I mean, Dendile watches this with this sort of, again, kind of weak smile. Dominic, on that subject of conducting a mass, erecting a cross and all that kind of thing. By this point, is it not also an obligation on the part of Spaniards meeting with pagans that they have to read out a pronouncement. Oh yes. The requirement it's called, isn't it?
一次，汤姆，让你非常高兴的是基督教的展示。所以他们竖起了一个十字架，他和他的手下都做了祈祷。你可以想象那个场景。我的意思是，滕迪莱带着那种，同样，那种虚弱的微笑看着这一切。多米尼克，关于举行弥撒、竖立十字架之类的事情。到这个时候，西班牙人与异教徒会面时，是否也有义务宣读一份声明。哦，是的。这就是所谓的“要求书”，不是吗？
Yeah, the requirements. Requiremento. So since the mid-1510s, it has been a legal requirement that a Spanish captain arriving in the New World seeking to subjugate new, must read them this legal document that is- In Spanish. In Spanish, history of the world, and a sort of explanation of how Jesus came and everybody must be Christian. The King of Spain is doing God's work.
是的，要求书。Requerimiento。所以自1510年代中期以来，法律规定，一名抵达新世界寻求征服新领土的西班牙船长，必须向他们宣读这份法律文件，这是——用西班牙语。用西班牙语，世界历史，以及关于耶稣是如何降临的解释，每个人都必须成为基督徒。西班牙国王正在做上帝的工作。
You are now a vassal of Spain. You must be Christians. If you're in breach of your obligations, we will kill you. Yeah. You know, all this. be Christians. If you're in breach of your obligations, we will kill you. He's got to read this in Spanish, even if people are hurling spears at him. I think two things to say about that. The first is that, of course, to our way of thinking, it's grotesque, but this is not simply a 21st century perspective. Again, Las Casas, who keeps appearing as a commentary on what the conquistadors
你现在是西班牙的附庸。你们必须成为基督徒。如果你违反了你们的义务，我们将杀死你们。是的。你知道，所有这些。成为基督徒。如果你违反了你们的义务，我们将杀死你们。他必须用西班牙语读这个，即使人们在向他投掷长矛。我想关于这一点有两件事要说。第一是，当然，按照我们的想法，这是荒诞的，但这不仅仅是21世纪的视角。同样，拉斯卡萨斯，他在这些剧集中不断作为征服者所作所为的评论员出现，他谈到要求书时说，这是不公正、不虔诚、可耻、非理性和荒谬的。当然它是荒谬的。这是精神错乱。我的意思是，这完全是疯狂的。而那是因为真正的目标不是原住民。而是欧洲的其他基督徒。是的。
are doing throughout these episodes, he says of the requirement that it was unjust, impious, scandalous, irrational, and absurd. Of course it's absurd. It's mental. I mean, it's completely deranged. And that's because the real target is not the natives. It's other Christians back in Europe. Yeah.
这反过来又突显了西班牙人在法律思维上非常、非常严谨的方式。汤姆，我认为他们是非凡的。我认为阅读这个故事，令人惊奇的是，在这些他们认为的冒险活动中，当然，现在的批评者会说这些是涉及可怕战争罪行的恐怖战役，但他们会把这些视为他们的伟大冒险。但他们必须在法律上证明它们的合理性。因为他们不断停下来签署合同，在律师面前作证。这对他来说真的很重要，因为实际上作为一名征服者，发生在你身上的两件事，
Which in turn kind of highlights the way in which the Spanish are very, very legalistically minded. They're extraordinary, Tom, I think. I think reading this story, the amazing thing is that in the middle of these, what they would perceive as their adventures, of course, a critic now would say these are horrendous campaigns involving terrible war crimes, but they would see them as their great adventures. But they have to justify them legally. As they keep stopping and signing contracts, making depositions before lawyers. And this really matters to them because actually the two things that happen to you as a conquistador,
可能发生在你身上的两件事，第一，你会在丛林中的某个地方死于可怕的死亡，或者第二，你会在西班牙度过最后20年，卷入法律案件，被其他征服者起诉和反诉。这就像现在的美国。他们生活在这个极其法律化的世界里。诉讼世界。诉讼世界。我的意思是，科尔特斯受过法律训练。这是有原因的，因为要成为一名官僚，要晋升，你需要法律训练。而西班牙人，当然，拉斯卡萨斯和其他人认为要求书简直是怪异。为什么要用西班牙语读这些法律文件？但他们中很多人确实很认真地对待它。
the two things that could happen to you, one, you will die a horrible death in the jungle at some point, or two, you will spend the last 20 years embroiled in legal cases back in Spain, being sued and countersued by other conquistadors. It's like the United States now. They live in this incredibly legalistic world. Litigious world. Litigious world. I mean, Cortes has trained in law. There's a reason for that because to be a bureaucrat, to advance, you needed a legal training. And the Spanish, of course, Las Casas and other people think the requirement is just bizarre. Why are you reading this legal documents in Spanish? But lots of them take it quite seriously.
科尔特斯无疑带着一份要求书的副本航行，并且几乎可以肯定一直在向人们宣读它。所以也许就是在这一点上。我的意思是，谁知道呢？但还有一个想法，拉斯卡萨斯被誉为一位因身为人类而主张美洲原住民拥有权利的人，并以此被纪念。这显然是我们21世纪遗产的关键部分。但要求书中也隐含着某种东西，那就是它承认居住在这些土地上的原住民拥有土地的权利。我的意思是，他们基本上被要求放弃它，毫无疑问。但某种程度上，我的意思是，提出这个论点听起来会很奇怪，但从长远来看，
Cortés undoubtedly sailed with a copy of the requirement and almost certainly kept reading it to people. So maybe it was at this point. I mean, who knows? But just one further thought, Las Casas is celebrated and commemorated as a man who argues that the Native Americans have rights by virtue of being human. And that's obviously a crucial part of our inheritance in the 21st century. But there is also something implicit in the requirement, which is that it's acknowledging that the native peoples who live in these lands have a right to the lands. I mean, they're being asked to basically to give it up, no question about that. But kind of, I mean, it will sound weird to make this argument, but in the long run,
正是这种对原住民拥有他们所居住土地权利的承认，将再次为现在被视为理所当然的事情提供法律基础，即原住民拥有其祖先所占领土地的权利。是的。西班牙人非常认真地对待所有这些法律细节。在16世纪后期，有代表团前往西班牙，前往皇家法院，说，早在1520年左右，我们的祖先与征服者达成了协议，
it's this acknowledgement that native peoples do have rights to the land that they inhabit that will provide the legal basis again for something that is taken for granted now, that indigenous peoples have rights to the lands that their ancestors have occupied. Yeah. The Spanish take all these legal niceties incredibly seriously. And later on in the 16th century, there are delegations that will go to Spain, to the royal court, to say, back in 1520, whatever, our ancestors made a deal with the conquistadors,
现在你们必须遵守那个协议。有时他们会赢得官司。对。西班牙人比北美洲的英国定居者更尊重这些。哦，是的。毫无疑问。西班牙人认真对待这些东西。大炮。他让他的手下骑马四处走动。阿兹特克人在看到马匹时因恐惧而脸色苍白。他们确实被炮火之类的东西震慑住了。现在，科尔特斯对滕迪莱说，我很想见见你们的皇帝。我很想看看你们的首都。滕迪莱说，不，不，不。我们遭遇了严重的干旱。你不能那样做。然后发生了一次致命的交流，或者至少我们认为可能发生了。这是一个被高度神话化的时刻。科尔特斯被认为说过，
and now you have to honor that deal. And sometimes they win the cases. Right. The Spanish are much more respectful of these than, say, the English settlers are in North America. Oh, yeah. Undoubtedly. The Spanish take this stuff respectful of these than, say, the English settlers are in North America. cannons. He gets his men to ride around. The Aztecs turn white when they see the horses with fear. They're genuinely shaken by the cannon fire and stuff. Now, Cortes says to Tendile, I would love to meet your emperor. I would love to see your capital. And Tendile says, no, no, no. We've got a terrible drought. You can't do that. Then there is a fatal exchange, or at least we think there probably was. It's a much mythologized moment. Cortez is supposed to have said,
你们有很多黄金吗？滕迪莱说，当然，我们有很多黄金。科尔特斯说，哦，那太好了，因为我们患有一种心脏病，只有黄金才能治愈。我的意思是，这是科尔特斯被认为说过的最著名的话之一。我仍然能看到迈克尔·伍德在电视上说这句话
do you have lots of gold? And Tindale says, of course, we have loads of gold. And Cortez says, oh, that's great because we suffer from a sickness of the heart, which can be cured only by gold. I mean, that's one of the most famous things that Cortez is ever supposed to have said. I can still see Michael Wood saying it on TV
在《征服者》系列中，因为这是一个伟大的故事。但我怀疑这是否可能是一种事后添加的故事，就像许多这类事情一样。然而，令人着迷的是，他们仍然没有见过的城市里的皇帝不断给他们送礼物。更多的黄金、珠宝、羽毛、各种小饰品作为礼物送来。现在，如果有人小时候读过这个故事，或者读过休·托马斯的《征服》，或者读过威廉·普雷斯科特19世纪版本的这个故事，他们就会知道蒙特祖马和阿兹特克人认为西班牙人是神，
in the series, Conquistadors, because it's a great story. But I wonder whether that might be a sort of after-the-fact kind of story bolted on, as so many of these things may be. However, what is fascinating is the emperor in the city that they have still not seen keeps sending them gifts. More gifts arrive of gold, of jewelry, of feathers, of trinkets of various kinds. Now, if anybody has ever read the story as a child, or they've read Hugh Thomas's book, Conquest, or they've read the William Prescott's 19th century version of this story, they will know that Montezuma and the Aztecs thought the Spanish were gods,
他们送礼物是绝望地试图让他们远离，他们害怕他们。但我认为公平地说，汤姆，现代历史学家对这个故事极其怀疑。我想不出有哪位现代历史学家认为阿兹特克人认为西班牙人是神。当时没有证据表明他们认为他们是神。所以科尔特斯确实写信给查理五世国王，告诉他他在做什么。他在那些信中从未说过，我被误认为是神。但最早提到这一点是在16世纪中期，不是吗？完全正确。所以贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯，那位征服者，我的意思是，甚至他可能是在编造，可能是在弄错。即使是他，我的意思是，我认为他绝对是在编造。
that they were sending them the gifts in a desperate attempt to keep them away, that they were terrified of them. But I think it's fair to say, isn't it, Tom, that modern historians are exceedingly suspicious of this story. I cannot think of a single modern historian who thinks that the Aztecs thought the Spaniards were gods. There's no evidence at the time they think they're gods. So Cortes does write letters to King Charles V, tell him what he's up to. And he never says in those letters, I was mistaken for a god. But the earliest reference to it is mid-16th century, isn't it? Exactly. So Bernal Diaz, the conquistador, I mean, even he may be making things up, may be getting things wrong. Even he, I mean, he's definitely making things up, I think.
嗯，我们以后会谈到他，但是的。但他可能是我们最好的当代来源，西班牙来源。他从未说过他们认为我们是神。他说他们像对待贵族一样对待我们，像对待领主一样对待我们，他们给了我们礼物和所有这些事情，但他从未说过他们认为埃尔南·科尔特斯是羽蛇神的转世之类的。所以卡米拉·汤森的论点是，墨西加人试图弄清楚这些人是谁。他们是谁？他们总是通过家乡来识别人们，而他们不知道这些人来自什么家乡。但他们开始将西班牙人与对上帝的深切虔诚联系起来，因为他们不断谈论基督等等。所以他们开始
Well, we'll talk about him in due course, but yeah. But he's probably our best contemporary source, Spanish source. He never says they thought we were gods. He says they treated us like nobles, they treated us like lords, they gave us gifts and all this business, but he never says they thought Hernan Cortes was the reincarnation of Quetzalcoatl or whatever. So Camilla Townsend, her argument is that the Mexica are trying to work out who these people are. Who are they? They always identify people by their homeland and they don't know what the homeland is that these people are coming from. But the one thing that they come to identify the Spanish with is a profound devotion to their God because they keep going on about Christ and so on. And so they come to
认为他们是神的使者，而且纳瓦特尔语中似乎有一个词，如果你是神的使者，但在16世纪的过程中，这个词演变成了，是的，某种神圣起源的人。所以她认为这可能就是发生的事情，但我认为阿兹特克人从未认为他们是神。我的意思是，另一种可能性是阿兹特克人使用，我的意思是，高地位的阿兹特克语言非常华丽。他们的习语非常华丽。你知道，你是一位伟大的领主，了不起的人，所有这些东西。而西班牙人可能只是误解了。但如果科尔特斯被当作神对待，他会说的。我想是的，是的。而且他没有被当作神对待，无论如何，他现在在海岸上，顺便说一句，他在这一点上做了一件非常奇怪的事情，这是
think that they are emissaries from a god and there is apparently some word in now what that if your emissaries of a god but it can over the course of the 16th century this word shaded into becoming yeah someone of divine origin and so she argues that that's perhaps what happened but i think the aztecs never thought that they were gods. I mean, another possibility is the Aztecs use, I mean, high status Aztec language is very flowery. Their idiom is very flowery. You know, you're a great Lord, amazing person, all this kind of stuff. And the Spanish may simply have misunderstood. But Cortes would say if he'd been treated as a god. I think so, yeah. And he wasn been treated as a god i think so yeah and he wasn't treated as a god anyway he's there on the coast now he does something very odd at this point by the way this
决定的关键时刻，他要么可以完全违抗命令深入内陆，要么可以做格里哈尔瓦所做的事情，那就是沿着海岸走一点，然后回去向维拉斯奎兹报告。这就是我认为他的性格如此重要的地方，因为许多其他人此时会回去并服从他们的命令。就在这一点上，科尔特斯成为了历史书中的那个科尔特斯，因为他说，去他的命令。我要深入内陆，亲自寻找那座城市。我想他一定被马林切告知，你会找到盟友，你很强大，而阿兹特克人很弱。他一定有某种动力这样做，因为他正走进……因为否则，这太疯狂了。
is the crucial moment of decision he can either go inland completely disobeying his orders or he can do what grialva did which is potter along the coast a bit and then go back and report back to velazquez and this is where i think his character is so important because lots of other people would have gone back at this point and obeyed their orders. And it's at this point that Cortes becomes the Cortes that ends up in the history books because he says, sod my orders. I'm going to go inland and find the city for myself. He must have been told, I imagine, by Malinche, you will find allies, that you are strong and the Aztecs are weak. He must have had some incentive to do this because he's walking into... Because otherwise, it's insane.
对，完全正确。这是一件疯狂的事情。他召集了他的手下，对他们说，看，我知道我们都说我们要回去。我知道我们有维拉斯奎兹的命令。然而，如果他在这里，他会看到这是一片多么好的土地，如果我们在这里建立一个城镇，对上帝和国王来说是多么令人高兴。顺便说一句，这就是法律主义。他说，让我们在这里的海岸上建立一个城镇。我们将称它为维拉里卡德拉维拉克鲁斯，真十字架的富裕城镇。我们都将成为该镇的公民。每个人在镇议会中都有投票权。让我们现在就进行
Right, exactly. It's a mad thing to do. And he gathers his men and he says to them, look, I know we all said we'd go back. I know we've got the orders from Velazquez. However, if he were here, he would see what a fine land this is and how pleasing it would be to God and the king if we were to build a town here. This is the legalism, by the way. He says, let's found a town here on the coast. And we will call it the Villa Rica de la Vera Cruz, the rich town of the true cross. And we'll all be citizens of the town. Everybody gets a vote in the town council. Let's have the
镇议会选举。我的意思是，这听起来太奇怪了。西班牙人举行了镇议会选举。他们都有投票权。惊喜，惊喜，议员们统治了党的队长。他们都说，让我们去做吧。他们确实做了。科尔特斯正式辞去了探险队负责人的职务。他们立即说，你不再是探险队的负责人。我们任命你为我们城镇的首席法官和总队长。这听起来是一件绝对怪异的事情，但这给了他法律制裁。它使他免于因违抗命令而被起诉。但同时，它回到了我们之前谈到的内容，即这不是一次军事探险。
town council elections right now. I mean, this will sound so weird. The Spanish have the town council elections. They all have a vote. Surprise, surprise, the councillors rule the captains of the party. And they all say, let's go for it. They do. Cortes formally resigns as head of the expedition. And they immediately say, you are no longer the head of the expedition. We are appointing you chief justice and captain general of our town. This sounds like an absolutely bizarre thing to do, but this gives him legal sanction. It indemnifies him against being prosecuted for disobeying his orders. But also, it goes back to what we were talking about earlier, that this is not a military expedition.
科尔特斯不是作为一名拥有官方职级的总队长在那里。他必须说服所有这些有着不同竞争、不同忠诚的移动群体与他同行。是的。当然，他知道他们中的一些人是维拉斯奎兹的人，他们也必须被处理。他确实这样做了，他以一种非常狡猾的方式摆脱了他们，但这将以巨大的后果反过来伤害他。所以他说，首先要做的是我们需要把所有的财宝送回去，
Cortes is not there as a captain general with people with official ranks below him. He has to persuade all these kind of moving groups of people with different rivalries, different loyalties, to go with him. Yes. And he knows, of course, that some of them are Velazquez's men, and they have to be dealt with as well. He does, and he gets rid of them in a very cunning way, but one that will come back to bite him with massive consequences. So he says, the first thing to do is we need to send all the treasure back,
不是送回古巴，而是送回西班牙。让我们把它送回给国王。这是他在国王发现他违抗命令时讨好国王的好方法。他说，做这件事的完美人选是你，弗朗西斯科·德·蒙特霍。所以这是维拉斯奎兹在船上的主要盟友。这是让他带着所有财宝离开这个等式并赢得西班牙国王信任的好方法。所以他这样做了。然后他做了那件已经成为传奇的事情。所以当蒙特霍离开时，他说，剩下的船……现在，很多人会想，啊，他烧了它们，因为那是传说。他没有烧他的船。那是亚历山大大帝风格的。尤利安背教者。
not to Cuba, but to Spain. Let's send it back to the king. This is a good way of him buttering up the king when the king finds out he's disobeyed his orders. And he says, the perfect person to do this is you, Francisco de Montejo. So this is Velazquez's chief ally on his ships. It's a good way of getting him out of the equation with all the treasure and buying credit with the king of Spain. So he does that. And then he does this thing that has gone down in legend. So as Montejo is off, he says, the rest of the ships... Now, a lot of people will think, aha, he burns them because that's the legend. He doesn't burn his ships. That's a very Alexander the Great style. Julian the Appestate.
是的。某种传说。完全正确。实际上，他所做的是他说，我们会把它们搁浅，拖到岸上，因为我们不再需要它们了。我们不需要它们漂浮在海上。因为如果它们留在海里，它们会腐烂，不是吗？完全正确。我们将把一些木材用于我们的新城镇。他们确实建造了这个新城镇。拥有一个基地对他们来说很重要。他留下了一些手下。所以他搁浅了他的船，现在他不能回去了。这也向任何胆小的人传达了一个信息，当然。无论你喜欢与否，我们都要继续前进。然后当他们都准备好时，已经是1519年8月16日了，他告诉他的手下在海滩上集合。他们像往常在大时刻之前一样举行了弥撒。然后他走上前去告诉他们
Yeah. Kind of legend. Exactly. Actually, what he does is he says, we'll beach them, drag them up onto the shore because we don't need them anymore. We don't need them floating in the sea. Because they'd rot, wouldn't they, if they were left in the sea? Exactly. And we will use some of the timber for our new towns. They do build this new town. It's important for them to have a base. And he leaves some of his men behind. So he beaches his ships and he now can't go back. And it also sends a message, of course, to any faint hearts. We are going on whether you like it or not. And then by the time they've all got ready, it is the 16th of August, 1519, and he tells his men to assemble on the beach. They have mass, as they always do before a big moment. Then he steps up to tell them
他的计划。一个激动人心的时刻，关键时刻，西班牙人准备向这座听起来极其可怕的城市、伟大帝国的伟大首都进军？这是疯狂吗？这是勇气吗？他们是否可能被拉马林切甚至被墨西加人自己欺骗了，这是一个最近才提出的理论，也许我们会在下一集中讨论。但无论如何，这是一个关键时刻。在我们的下一集中，你可以听到科尔特斯的计划是什么，以及向特诺奇蒂特兰进军的成果，以及科尔特斯和蒙特祖马之间的伟大对抗。所以一切即将到来，绝对激动人心。现在，如果你乐意等待，你乐意等待。也许期待会让一切变得更伟大。但如果你不想等待，你当然可以加入“其余历史俱乐部”，
his plan. A thrilling moment, pivotal moment, Spanish preparing to march on this incredibly terrifying sounding city, great capital of a great empire? Is it madness? Is it courage? Have they perhaps been deceived either by La Milice or maybe even by the Mexica themselves, which is a theory that's very recently been put forward and perhaps we'll discuss in the next episode. But anyway, a pivotal moment. And in our next episode, you can hear what Cortez's plan was and the fruits of the march on Tenochtitlan and the great confrontation between Cortez and Boc de Zuma. So all to come, absolutely thrilling stuff. Now, if you're happy to wait, you're happy to wait. And maybe the anticipation will just make it all the greater. But if you don't want to wait, you can, of course, join the Restless History Club,
在那里，所有描述这段非凡历史的剧集都在等着被收听。所以去restlesshistorypod.com，我们将在下一集中回来，要么几乎立即，要么几天后，无论如何，我们很快就会见到你，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《其余是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。
where all the episodes describing this extraordinary episode in history are waiting to be listened to. So go to the restlesshistorypod.com and we will be back with the next episode, either almost immediately or in a few days time either way we'll see you soon bye-bye bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。